Malcolm dies as an orthodox Muslim
who does not believe in the superiority
of One race over the other
finds great Tranquility in the practice
of the Hajj
um great clarity and I think you read
his letters from Mecca
and he talks about his his change his
transformation in particular and it was
a process it's a process for him
but he inspires the likes of Muhammad
Ali to become the person that he becomes
and inspires many other people
uh till today
to really
see themselves and see the world
differently in light of that
understanding of monotheism
so he was deeply a man of faith and
throughout his life the nature of that
faith has changed as he grew as he
interacted with
I would say a cruel society that he was
living right right
uh you mentioned he inspired uh Muhammad
Ali who I don't think is an
overstatement to say is probably the
most quite possibly the most famous
American Muslim from America because you
maybe make a few comments as an athlete
yourself uh What
uh what impact uh did uh Islam have on
Muhammad Ali's life and what and vice
versa what impact did he have as a
leader as a religious figure uh on the
Muslim Community
I think Muhammad Ali his quotes on on
Islam are precious because he talks
about how he sought the wealth of this
world and he found it in Islam he found
a greater meaning and he attributes
everything that he became to his faith
uh his sense of strength and commitment
the willingness to take a stand uh
for the truth
when it was extremely unpopular
on the basis of his faith and on the
basis of his integrity
uh I think that he inspired people with
his confidence
and
his coherence I mean he was incredibly
eloquent
I mean poetic
and just unwavering
seemed unbreakable so as Relentless as
he was in the ring he was even more so
outside of the Ring the man could not be
broken
and everything was stacked up against
them but he perseveres and he does so
then through Parkinson's
and chooses to live a life of
of giving a life of service a life of
using his platform
to bring up issues of importance and to
Champion the rights of others so he
wasn't satisfied at any point in his
life would simply being a boxing grade a
boxing champion
he uses it for so much more
and so he goes down as one of the most
famous Americans period of the 20th
century one of the most transformative
Americans period of the 20th century not
just American Muslims
uh and a lot of people that loved him
when he died
would not have loved him if they were
around in the 1960s and 1970s
you know they said they loved him when
he couldn't speak anymore you know many
of those who celebrated him at the time
his death
would have been his greatest opponents
at the peak of his career and when he
was taking the stands that he was taking
yeah he was fearless and part of this
his faith was helping him take the
Fearless stance but throughout all of it
given the strength I think he's also a
symbol of compassion through all the way
through all the fun kind of
yeah the poetic nature of who who he was
in The Fearless nature who he was
there's always like a like a deep love
for for the sport
and for Humanity absolutely and that's
the thing right that was so obvious that
despite everything that had happened to
him
he never loses himself neither to the
fame nor to the fear yeah he he always
stays himself he's authentic
um and you know when I went to his
funeral and it was one of the most
beautiful
things I'd ever seen because
everyone
in Louisville Kentucky had a story with
Muhammad Ali right the guy that he saves
from committing suicide the school kids
the the hotel shuttle driver the gas
station worker everyone has a story of
Muhammad Ali in Louisville Kentucky
and when he
when he when he passes away
everybody comes out and stands in front
of their homes and they take the casket
and they drive around the streets of
Louisville and he had this dream I'm
very close to some of his uh some of his
children
incredible people by the way uh just
incredible human beings
and he had this dream that he shared
with them that
um he was jogging around the streets of
Louisville Kentucky
and everyone had come out to wave to him
and so he's running around jogging and
and waving to everybody in the streets
of Louisville Kentucky then he gets to
the cemetery and he says he flies into
the heavens
so his his dream and he had this dream
years ago I mean if you look at his
funeral
it's such a beautiful
you can't make it up it's such a
beautiful
moment where it seems to come to reality
because everybody in Louisville just
comes out and just Waves by says casket
and then when he gets to the cemetery
the gates close and
he goes off to be with his Lord and we
pray that it's a good place for him